welcome to this video playing I always
have difficulties to identify a
dissonant and an L on I yeah well
playing this I am here from Argentina
going for yeah actually had a request
for 97 I should have played that for
once okay but let's get ahead am playing
um this in a very simple fashion not not
not bad I mean just rather unambitious
okay
I just want to know him a bit it son
it's a good post on d5 attacking a two
so you cannot easily em casa long hmm
yeah interesting as always be five in
this position this type of position but
ok maybe I can annoy him a bit with
fruit Jade or here not bad at all I can
always casts a long so taking g2 maybe
you can play d 5 but I don't really
think so and I'm the fibers bit
premature so just castles yeah why not
yeah I should turn white plano long
castles
I'm this Bishop where should i do d6 not
sure okay but let's not spend too much
time play couple of routine like moves
to improve it to improve this position
an interesting ideas is this b5 and in
this type of type of structure try to
fight for the for the square or in a d5
but don't really want to do that in this
concrete position
maybe this one and now I'm uppity and
this setting up this sort of semi pin
okay not sure what this move is doing
maybe I should have stayed on that five
it's always a bit annoying for his king
that he cannot go King be one king a one
I don't know maybe 24 was wasn't so
great uh-huh surprising didn't think
that this would be a wouldn't be too
bright I thought this this kind of
position um would be okay for me night
hy5 of course is Sam is a big problem
but I thought he wouldn't wouldn't
manage Queen a4 move like this but maybe
I'm I'm wrong
and we have died this doesn't look good
I mean this is not necessarily fatal the
the night on 85 but it looks really bad
yeah can you do to move the Queen try to
get some play with maybe against the d5
pawn something like this night attacking
the spawn
hmm
yeah this doesn't look too great maybe
I'm just in time to get enough play
maybe now I'm attacking the spawn but
I'm not really threatening anything here
I don't think so can give this check but
just just King king air one
hmm
intact we'd be five what about Quinn be
five yeah it's not really attacking it's
not really attacking it hmm wait wait
look this ham hock t7 night hmm it's not
working unfortunately
yeah I know this is just a bacta
possibles but I didn't see a good good
one hoping that he somehow screws up
this don't don't understand that why
would you open the jihad is the direct
to direct kill here
Wow
now we need to where'd you go with the
screen it's not like I'm having no ideas
here 95 can I take it i think i can take
it
now i know i will take it this isn't
this winning for black hard to believe
what white would survive this God got
lots lots of things going on the king
yeah this is what I actually feared ok
let's take first
isn't that when I can't believe this
check time morning check
I was just hoping that this attack is
still is still good enough couldn't
spend spend so much time check
check check check
I don't know we both had eight seconds
and I know it's a total crapshoot from
here yeah I'm probably lost him looks
like what should win you he should win
win points here but I was certainly ah
this must have been winning this
position isn't this winning come on show
me how to do it it's just a job no it's
even better for white this is this is
cool and computer gifts this is a sequel
completely equal interesting and rukia
this is the sea even says is better for
white yet sometimes amazing it looks
like white is just dodging bullets here
but it seems to be okay and yeah amazing
yeah this is even the best according to
computer this is worse I don't have a
good follow up here cooperate and then
we get this position you can actually
take amazingly huh cool yeah impossible
to manage this in 20-something seconds
just we f here at four were so we'd move
it looked very nice for white and
therefore just I don't know it seems to
him should be okay now 96 is a good move
now okay no it wrong knight c6 take rook
e8 the idea
I know probably I could analyze this for
hours 95 is the computer suggestion yeah
but it's just a theoretical thing I mean
if I was a 4 s just the move any human
would play yeah an interesting game
thanks for watching